this is utter incompetence the market
doesn't believe them I don't believe
them I don't believe a word that they
say and it's going to make things much
worse for your listeners housing markets
going to be in trouble mortgages are
going to go up housing quantities are
going to decline it's the same utter
group thinking competence in 2008 in the
same bank the bank of England missed the
greatest financial crisis since 1929 and
here they go again the market doesn't
believe them I don't believe them your
listeners shouldn't believe them
screeching u-turns are coming and bad
economic data is coming this is terrible
incompetence and this lot should just
quit so some screeching u-turns ahead in
your view from the bank of England I
mean there is some thought that the
there might be another rise in June in
interest rates do you think that might
not happen
well who knows what the incompetent
might do